my aim isn't what it used to be
long gone are the days of me quick
scoping clutching out
1v5s or grabbing pentakills like they
were nothing
maybe i'm getting too old and too slow
or maybe the new generation is just that
much better and faster but with that
being
said i want to improve i want to get
better again i want
to enjoy my first-person shooter games i
want to minimize the amount of loot lost
in escape from tarkov i want to maximize
my kd
in call of duty and just feel competent
at one of my favorite genres again
and just enjoy shooters that little bit
more
so in an effort to do that i installed
aimlab and i i'll admit
i only heard of aimlab because they
entered the four guys skin competition
but when i looked into it and i started
fiddling with the program it was
actually really promising
with what the thing was offering in
terms of
separating your aiming skill into
pillars of speed
precision flicking all that sort of
thing it seemed really promising
so for the last week i've been playing
aim lab every day from anywhere between
30 minutes to an hour
i've done seven days every day does
an aim trainer like aim lab help has it
improved my skill my performance and my
kd
well you're about to see okay so first
day of my training i think i'm gonna
stick with the suggested
tasks for now it's day one i'm gonna
trust aimlab i've
knocked my mouse settings lower than
they've ever been i'm at
450 dpi with a polling rate of 1000
hertz
i'm expecting to be trash the first time
around
but that's the whole point of this right
learning to aim in a new way trying to
get a bit better
we'll do half an hour of aim training
we'll see how that goes day one then
we'll play half an hour of call of duty
see how that goes day one and we'll just
take
our average kd from day one to day seven
the results will be more like do i feel
like i'm performing better
let's get into it let's see how we do
not as quick as i wanted it to be
honestly not as quick as i wanted it to
be
okay so i've got weaknesses my reaction
time is well below average
if you're currently focused improving
accuracy though this is okay
otherwise play more speed mode tasks
such as spider shot speed reflex shutter
speed or motion
shot speed okay that's good to know
what's really good
with this that i've just found is that
you can put in what
game you're trying to train for and it
will reflect those settings
so i've set it to my ecology warzone
settings and and and put all the values
pretty much the same
this feels more like you're training for
a specific game rather than training
overall skill but i think it's still
going to be really valuable
slightly better accuracy i'll take that
i've got something called
hypometria which sounds like a skin
disease
you are falling short of the target
you're trying to hit
so try raising your sensitivity or just
with continued practice i think i'm
think i'm just going to keep
on keeping on we've got another
six hours 50 minutes of training to do
just in in this so
hopefully hopefully we'll see some
improvement oh god i hope we see some
improvement
i've got poor tracking and i'm
inefficient and such a pro gamer after
all
i've wanted to learn to aim better at
lower sensitivity for a while
but my mouse isn't big enough like when
it when it's panning all the way to the
right i'm at the end of my mouse map and
then i have to pick up my mouse and
flick it again
a lot of people i see on twitch i'll
have these gargantuan mouse mats in
their
big sweeping motions um whereas my mouse
mat at the minute
is this big i feel i feel like i'm i'm
not as bad as i think i am when it comes
to target acquisition
tracking is definitely my weak point and
i've known that for a while i've always
struggled with tracking targets
i i'm definitely relying on my spray
much more here i can feel it already
i actually got some good things that it
seems
my reaction time this task was less than
350 milliseconds
oh so my so my reaction speed is get is
getting there and that we've only been
doing this for
20 minutes
i mean that triangle looks promising but
my accuracy
just from today has improved from 49
to 62 my score's gonna my average time
on target
has gone up average time off target has
gone down
so all this stuff on the left hand
column is good
so my settings now are exactly the same
in call of duty
as they were in aimlab so i'm kind of
interested to see
in how it is in like in game
probably just shouldn't have jumped in
there no matter how good my aim may get
it wouldn't stop me from making stupid
decisions in the game
oh crumbs falling off my mouse man again
that's it's gonna be an issue
i felt like i was tracking that guy's
head a bit better than i would normally
i really hate having to pick my mouse up
and
put it down again i can see a bigger
mouse mat in my future
i wasn't happy with my performance in
that game
i'll be honest hopefully and by the end
of the week we'll be
smashing some ground war so day two new
mouse
knew me all the problems i was having
yesterday problem solved i've upgraded
i'm a real gamer now i've got myself one
of the new
razer naga pros and i've paired it with
their akari
what sizes thing cari mouse mat let me
tell you
he's so smooth it's so good i'm a sucker
for like extra mouse buttons
and i have these really nice ones on the
side but now
now we're at day two i've lost the
excuse of blaming my hardware
oh yeah this feels better i'm still
getting used to like doing big motions
with my wrist
my time to kill was a lot faster my
skull was a lot lower so i still got
hypermetria
i'm falling short poor flicking just my
accuracy
slow hand and inefficient
i suck i suck so bad
this is this is why we train this is why
we train it's fine i'm going to focus in
on aspects
so there was those complaints of my
speed there so i'm going to play
the speed mode say the song behind me i
want to be able to go what
in one sweep of a mouse i think i think
that's the sensitivity i should get used
to
encompassing all the training my overall
weakness is left side
you perform much better eliminating
targets to your right than your left we
can fix that
poor tracking inefficient that's my
objective of this week i want to get rid
of those two
weaknesses just because they're already
appearing so much
it's making me self-conscious right so
i've just been playing
nothing but spider shot precision for
the past 25 minutes
it's it's been up and down but i've just
hit high school i'm starting to
i start to feel like i'm hitting a
stride i'm still getting
some fairly weak weak you know insights
when it comes to my score my score was
way higher
i know it's a lot of my time to kill two
kills a second
my precision is getting lower and i'm
i'm not playing spider shot position
but i feel like if i'm just practicing
with speed
my precision will come with practice as
i'm getting used to the
the rapid movements intriguing
intriguing
it's i'm getting better scores we've
learnt our new mouse
i think i think i'm happy with it with
the way training's gone today i want to
try
the sandbox ai stuff this is meant to
kind of adapt to some of your weaknesses
uh and push push the boundary on those a
little bit i think i'm going
to go for some of those now
now i'm still getting a lot of the same
weaknesses that i've had
in the past trying not to get too bogged
down in the
immediate results and try to look at the
bigger picture as you can see on the
menu
flicking about 35 tracking 38 precision
i'm pretty decent at
speed perception and cognition are still
unknown factors
so i think i'm going to focus on the
unknown it's very easy to give into your
muscle memory
and like flick away fire then flick back
just assuming you've hit it okay let's
give that's giving me a spot for speed
that's my goal for this session
get all of these on the left numbered so
this is nothing to do
with aiming i just click as soon as i
see something
that was hiding behind my gun no false
alarms
got every target now i've got right side
weakness but when i'm
shooting stuff i have left side weakness
86 on perception that's obviously
way better than any of my other scores i
think by the seventh day i want all of
these numbers
to at least be like 60 plus ideally i
remembered
that line slow is smooth smooth is fast
how's that that was that
film was what film was that from it's
from shooter
that mark wahlberg sniper film
why is that embedded in my brain so
decision shot is meant to train my
cognition
how good me my gray matters working only
shoot target orbs if their color matches
the color of the center orb
just before shot just before the target
spawn so red to red blue to blue
i think i got all of those right god
damn right i did okay i want to see what
my stats are saying recognition is
pretty good so i'm i'm right i'm ranked
as platinum
platinum one nonetheless but i think my
end goal
all of these at least above 50. let's
see if we can get
into ruby that's like a good middle
yesterday we got to plat one so i think
i'm gonna do some flicking tracking
training today
again my objective is to get all the
scores
to like between 50 and 60.
again i'm gonna try and keep the number
of shots
per ball to a minimum
high score okay good time to go went
down accuracy is way up scores way up
slow and smooth smooth as fast okay but
it went from like 30
i want to say 34 was it 34 36 to 42
and that was in the space of 10 minutes
i don't think this is the uh endorsement
razer wanted but this smooth akari mouse
pad
let me tell you i've got some sweaty
gamer wrist
and i'm still just gliding off the thing
poor tracking and inefficient what kind
of super human tracking
do people have i want to see strengths
look at that there's something in the
strength column
oh you'd love to see it we have actually
gone up a
whole rank as well we're in ruby well we
started the video in platinum
and then we got to ruby four and now
we're in ruby three
this is both the training session that
i've gone hardest in and also seen
the most tangible progress and growth in
it's making me really excited for the
last few days of training
we made a lot of progress yesterday i'm
really hopeful that day five
has similar results for us made all the
way to ruby three which i'm
pretty happy with my goal is to still
get every stat
up to 50. i'm gonna play for half an
hour normally see how i feel
maybe doing another half an hour and
checking with you again after that one
thing i noticed though
from playing the line trace is that if i
want to go from here
to here with my crosshair i don't do
that
i do like this sort of motion it's
wasting time and it's not efficient
so maybe that will help fix that sort of
issue that i'm having
compared to the rest of the population
you're incredibly accurate in making
flick movements at targets
what's happened overnight where was
where's the slow hand and the
and the inefficient gun i'm not
complaining
okay in an effort to continue practicing
my flicking
love sniping and tarkov love sniping
call of duty playing the sniper mode
it's going to help with flicking but
also help with accuracy and
i do love me a long range headshot so
let's let's try this i've not done the
sniping mode before
slow it down dave slow and smooth smooth
as fast
lost the slow hand good happy that i've
i've actually gone up 0.7 so not a lot
but it's going up there i'm going to be
real with you i've done like another
hour it's i i can't
get flicking above 49
and it's been really frustrating me i i
did see a big increase when i started
to just go through
the entire list rather than stick to two
or three or four that i feel more
comfortable with
i feel like i've got room to improve
when it comes to sniping so i'm gonna
try that again
come on you can do this
i was slightly more accurate my time to
kill was lower
and that was a lower score i don't think
i don't think this is going to push me
to 50
i don't know 49 dead 49 dead
i've got to stop i've got to stop the
penultimate day is upon us stay six
yesterday i got me i got a bit tilted i
was trying to force
some training through into the grammar
that just wasn't going in i really
wanted to get flicking
above 50 but it wasn't to be um today
though
speed precision condition those are the
next ones to focus on
i can't even hit that center ball
the shocking absolutely shocking i'm
sidelining speed all right speed can
wait for another day
now you know what cognition's closed
conditions close to 50.
[Music]
all right let's see where we're sitting
we were 49
have we broken 50. 51 let's go
okay so ruby three let's try
precision
with that okay have we broken the 50 50
percentile
oh big moves big moves
before i finish stage training i'll do
one flicking let's do one flicking grid
shot
i was better than my worst i'm worried
that that's gonna actually make the
school go lower
no no no
we went down 0.1 no
there's still more a lot more left to do
we've got one more day and then it's
going to be
a big call of duty session and see
have i actually got any better
last day of my training i'm a little
nervous i
i really want to make the goal of
getting every stat above 50.
so i want to focus on flicking in speed
today
according to the box to the right it
says i'm improving although that did
feel pretty weak
but the weaknesses that i originally
started with aren't showing up anymore
it's just like
eh you fine i suppose
a little better a little better a little
better i'm a little good but i might
have to give up on the flicks
i have to give up i can't break that 50
barrier and i still
got some speed to try out as well
that the hypermetry is going to gonna
hold me for as long as i live
i just can't for the life of me get that
get rid of that
could not get that last one right where
we are we're at 41 and we are now at 41.
have i peaked have i peaked
[Music]
the high score still got the left side
weakness accuracy is the same
score went up time to kill went down
kills the second one up can't ask for
more than that really
training's over i'm pretty pleased i i
definitely feel like i've improved over
seven days i'm just gonna drop jump
straight into call of duty
see how i fare in a in an actual game
i was trying to melee what my melee in
for bullets hurt more than fists
again all the aim trading in the world
will not stop me from making silly
decisions in the heat of
gameplay
oh cheeky little triple there though so
i'm gonna take that to the bank
good tracking on that target there
oh we traded there 62 to 28
not too bad it's hard to say
for sure if i've got better or how much
i've got better
i feel like i'm better i feel like i'm
hitting more shots i feel like i'm
snapping to targets much faster
even if aim training is a placebo to
make me feel like i can perform better
or give me the confidence
to perform better i've definitely
improved definitely
i won't lie to you i didn't anticipate
this
seven day challenge to be quite as
mentally draining
as it turned out it was some of those
days were really tough
but you want to hear the stats like
obviously in the video we weren't
showing you
every game of call of duty i i was
playing plenty throughout the week
and at the start of the week seven days
ago my kd was somewhere between
0.86 and 1.12 that's the barrier that i
was seven days ago
now the past few hours and days that
i've been playing
my kd is somewhere between 1.98
and 2.21 so a
huge jump that represents a percentile
increase from anywhere between around 90
to 130 and that's just off
a week of training but if you look at
just the aimlab stats
they've grown on average across the
board about 40
again really great growth momentum and
progress
really happy with that but if we stop
talking about
just the core numbers and everything is
as promising and as great as they are
it's done something beyond
just being like oh yeah cool my kd's
increased it's actually made me look
at games the games i'm playing in a
different way
like i feel more confident to engage
in certain scenarios than i previously
were which in turn means that i'm
having more fights winning more fights
and increasing my kd so it's not just as
black and white as
i am now better at aiming the skills
that i feel like i've learned
has made me a braver first-person
shooter player
i'm taking on fights that i wouldn't
before and winning fights that i
definitely wouldn't before
and i think that's what the kd is now
representing
it's impressive i've i'm i'm pleased i'm
proud of the
the moves that i've made and the
progression that i've had
and i'm looking forward to like jumping
into more
first-person shooter games and keeping
like that skill
high am i gonna continue using aimlab
maybe i can definitely see it as a tool
of when i'm feeling rusty or if i need a
warm up before a stream or something
sure i'll knock out 20 minutes and knock
some of the rust off and
and feel a bit you know like i know
what's going on
as a daily thing probably not it was it
was pretty intense
but for me as someone who thought he was
like an average
to good first-person shooter player i
feel like
i mean i'm not shroud all of a sudden
i'm not pesterly
i'm not gonna start winning tournaments
but
i do now think i'm consistently good and
you know what else would be consistently
good
if you hit that like and subscribe
button so you can stay tuned
for more videos like this one i really
appreciate you joining me on this
strange little journey that i had um let
me know in the comment section below if
you've used aimlab or
if you're trying to get better at
first-person tutors or if this is going
to be something that
you think would be beneficial to you
i'll be in the comments section as soon
as this video is live to chat with you
guys
but if you miss me there you can always
find me on twitter at a regular dave
and until the next video thank you so
much for watching and i'll see you next
[Music]
time
you